have you guys noticed a pattern or a
trend
of a human trafficker so somebody who is
doing it what is a typical pattern
are you noticing a consistency with a
pattern or is it just a criminal that's
all it is they just kind of want to make
money
any kind of patterns you guys have found
yes uh
so we we build our own software uh we we
have our own data collection
and we we have those patterns we
actually sit on top of the largest human
trafficking database in existence
largest and cleanest uh we've got over
70 law enforcement agencies around the
united states that are all
kind of working together on this
database and so what that what that
means
is we've been able to take this very
very clean data
and start analyzing it for patterns and
now we're getting to the point
where our software is actually just
going to be able to actually can bring
human trafficking to
our attention so we know exactly how
they work
and really their achilles heel you know
i talk about this on
on other podcasts and people say well
nick how can you talk about what you're
doing don't you need to be secret about
it
nope i don't because if your business
model is that you need to be secretive
about something well that's not scalable
and that's that's not going to work uh
human traffickers have to advertise if
customers
want to find you know a date for the
night so to speak right that
usually the customers think it's
prostitution
and they they want to find that girl
they go to the internet
that's where this is all advertised
because if they put the girl on the
street
law enforcement can find it right law
enforcement has the right to go approach
her and talk to her
she might wrap the trafficker out so
it's a lot easier to keep her locked
into a
locked in a hotel room and advertise her
online
there's there's dozens of websites
online i mean you could
you could get to these websites if you
know where you're going this is not in
the deep and dark web this is the
front-facing internet
the big famous one that everybody was
aware of that the doj took down
was backpage.com and so
you go to those you go to those websites
you schedule a date with a girl
there's a human trafficker who's
advertising that girl online
and and the transaction happens so
that's the achilles heel
of of the whole human trafficking market
in the
in the united states is that it's
predominantly online
and so if you're online that means
you're leaving a trail
and we're really good at treat at uh
chasing down those trails and seeing
where they lead so i just looked at
backpage.com founder michael lacy who
was michael lacy
uh he is currently uh under house arrest
um he was actually uh so the village
voice
which was a publication out of new york
right from the 70s i think
they had the back page when the back
page was
right it was a lot of your uh your
prostitution massage parlors
a lot of human trafficking and then they
took they took that back page
of the newspaper and took it online and
started selling one dollar
advertisements um to people who were
predominantly engaged in the commercial
sex industry
and uh everybody their their whole
c-suite was arrested they all pled
guilty
uh michael including himself i know
michael lacy
and um i can't remember the other
founder's name off the top of my head
but they're fighting the charges because
they're old um
and you know they're they're gonna come
out of prison in a pine box if uh if
they get convicted or should we say when
they get convicted so they are
how did how did the law enforcement find
out that backpage was doing this behind
closed doors
uh we we decided we the liber fund
decided to make backpage our hobby
uh oh so you did that you went after
back page because i see 2018 and you've
been around for six years so
we were uh we were one of many many
members of a of a team
uh the the the real credit goes to
federal law enforcement
and uh and actually texas ag's office
they did a phenomenal job there's some
law enforcement in arizona that was
working the case as well
but when it came when it came to kind of
coordinating
a lot of the intelligence work and and
passing that off
uh we did uh we did a lion's share of
that for sure
so carl ferrer who was the ceo of
backpage i believe that's the name you
were trying to think about
did they know that human trafficking was
taking place and they kind of looked the
other way is that what the challenge was
yes they absolutely know that how did
they know that
because it's egregious uh i mean and any
any
any person who was looking at what was
happening
uh on their platform uh i mean they they
knew what was happening and the doj
actually has communications if you
research the back
back page case you'll find that's why
they pled guilty is because they were
literally talking about it on their
on their corporate communications uh so
they have the servers they
have everything that they were talking
about and they have them talking about
the fact that they knew this was
happening
um and they were they they were let me
give you
an example of the kind of thing that was
happening there there was a uh
a 12 year old girl who was advertised by
a human trafficker on backpage right so
you could tell in the
along with a photo and he put her age
as 12 years old well backpage's
moderators
change the age to 18 and then let
the ad go come on
absolutely evil i mean just just evil
so so i'm looking at alternative to back
pay so i'm assuming you target
craiglist.com
oilx facebook kg free ads
what are the websites you target that
can do exactly what backpage did
uh so i'm not going to give the names of
the the uh websites that we
target actively uh these websites are
very profitable and i'm not interested
in uh i'm not going to shut up okay in
that fight
um and and more importantly uh people
who don't know where to go telling them
where to go
uh but there's uh there's about 32 sites
right now
that are are the primary sites where the
source data comes from
uh and we we are actively
we're actively collecting from all of
those sites so let me ask you this when
you're dealing with a company
that say they don't know that that is
taking place
and then they find out based on the
proof you show because i think
your model isn't you go attack them your
model is you go team up with the 70 or
law enforcement organization that you
work with you no longer kick the doors
down you
give the intel to those to go kick the
doors down i think if after doing some
research on your business
model that's your business model right
correct okay so
so you find out a company that's a real
company
they have somebody who's a human
trafficker leveraging
the the the clientele the traffic that's
coming to that website
do you then contact them and have the
business
work with you to get more that data for
you to
pass down to law enforcement like do the
companies now help become a teammate
with you
that's always the first that's always
the first
place that we start so we have very
very publicly recognizable
partners publicly traded companies that
we work with to help them keep human
traffickers off of their platform
but a lot of these websites they
specifically moved
their business operations overseas into
non-friendly non-uh or non-friendly
non-extradition
u.s country countries so that they're
not
subject to u.s jurisdiction guidelines
that's kind of part of the problem
so how do you battle that right now
there's nothing we can really do
on that we we have a way of of diluting
their market
uh which we don't talk about publicly to
make it so that
it just complicates their business right
it just
it just makes it so that the the the
trafficker can never
quite get his product in front of the
customer and the customer can never
quite find a real product so we have
ways of of complicating that a little
bit
but primarily the way that the way that
we deal with that
is uh is by getting these human
traffickers arrested and that's that's
one
one key thing that we need to focus on
is
in order to have a human trafficking
victim which is the reason we're doing
this right
uh human traffickers are bad people
they're gonna do bad things
um there's nothing nick can do about
that however
they are they're exploiting people
they're harming
children and so the reason that there
are human trafficking victims
is because there are human traffickers
so we don't need to spend all of our
time
focusing on on rescuing victims we need
to focus on preventing victims by
getting
rid of human traffickers makes sense
i've not asked you this before
but i'm asking you right now and
hopefully you will do this as a
valuetainer please
share this video text it to people hit
the thumbs up button
share it whatever way you can for other
people to see it for the algorithms to
be on our favor because this is not a
message about how you make millions how
you make billions how you become
successful it's not entertainment this
is purely something that's about
education and awareness i'm asking you
share it with any parent that you know
and say just watch this video
get a paper and pen out you're going to
want to pay attention to this one here
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye-bye you